fun fact zu diesem videos paket wurde
beim nachbarn abgegeben und als ich das
abgeholt habe hat er mich ganz schön
doll angegrinst und dann hab ich gesehen
dass auf dem paket groß und deutlich
hanfprodukte steht ja hallo leute ich es
wieder einmal waren und will mit seinem
neuen test video und heute testen wir
hans produkt ich bin ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich gespannt weil ich nicht
vermutet habe das ist so viele hans
produkte gibt hans produkte hieß für
mich eigentlich immer
marianna also gras also high werden oder
halt es sind cookies rein backen aber
sonst habe ich nie gezeigt dass hanf
auch anders verwendet wird kann sein
dass ich auf dem mond lebe und die
einzige person die das dachte aber wir
wollen mal heute in die große welt des
hans rampf und auch wenn der thc-gehalt
in diesen produkten so niedrig ist dass
man davon eigentlich nicht heil werden
kann ist es doch mal ein guter test das
mal zu testen
richtig vanessa aber vorher ziehe ich
meine ohrringe aus ich kann keine
ohrringe tragen
ich möchte immer noch für videos
ohrringe tragen aber es funktioniert
einfach nicht meine ohren werden rot und
grün ein paket voller hand spaß für die
ganze familie
ta ta ta ta das erste was mir ins auge
springt ist das hanf mail das soll 8 bis
10% des mehls ersetzen aber warum sollte
man das benutzen auch zum verfeinern von
an binden von suppen und saucen ist es
bestens geeignet es verleiht den speisen
einen angenehmen nussigen geschmack für
sportler ist es eine gute pflanzliche
proteinquelle hanf mail ist frei von
gluten und zudem vegan warum ist hanf
mehr gesund es liefert omega 3 und omega
6 fettsäuren in einem perfekten
verhältnis von drei zu eins bringt eine
gute verdauung und eine sättigung gefühl
okay ist ideale eiweißquelle gamma
linolensäure für eine schöne haut und
haare hilft beim abnehmen sowie pms und
wird positiv bei entzündungen pms meint
jetzt wirklich pms man kann sagen dass
hanf mail quasi
allround supertalent ist wenn es um die
gesundheit geht kann ich mal riechen
marien
das riecht wie ein bauernbrot kennt ihr
so lange dauern brotteig sowie stanz
mail
das werde ich auf jeden fall mal zum
backen ausprobieren vielleicht mache ich
einen extra hand kuchen nur für euch wie
kann schon mal festhalten dass hanf auf
jeden fall so gesund sein soll das kommt
hier habe ich einmal hans marzipan und
hans frucht schnitte ihr fritz schnitten
kämpft ihr wahrscheinlich alle oder ich
würde sagen wir probieren erst mal dass
hans marzipan es sieht aus wie normales
marzipan hat aber so grüne flecken sieht
aus wie kräuter aber es ist
wahrscheinlich der hand riechen tut das
wie normales marzipan und jetzt bin ich
bin sehr gespannt warum sollte man hanf
in einen marzipan
ok es schmeckt definitiv anders als
normales marzipan
er schmeckt und ganz bisschen wie gras
riecht aber nur so lange ich wüsste
jetzt nicht warum man hanf marzipan
kaufen sollte aber auf jeden fall schon
gut heute kriegt ihr sogar ein paar
preise um die ohren dieser hand marzipan
hat drei euro 89 gekostet muss jetzt
nicht unbedingt sein
die frucht schnitte hartge kostet zwei
euro 29 okay sehr schön guten mutter
optischer
schmeckt auf jeden fall gesund das ist
gut aber nicht so mein ding und das
merke ich gar keinen hand oder irgendwie
unterschied nächstes das ist wie
weihnachten das ist das hanf
kräuterbutter gewürzt und randvoll
also das ist kräuterbutter gewürz das
heißt du machst damit kräuterbutter mit
eine schöne hanf kräuterbutter um das
thema geisel partie mit hanf produkten
nein lieber macht feiert keine partys
mit hans produkten ok rich gegründet
hanfblüten petersilie sellerie knoblauch
das schmeckt nach nichts wisst ihr was
ich machen wir eine kleine portion
kräuterbutter ich hoffe ihr könnt sehen
kräuterbutter ist jetzt fertig
bitteschön hand kräuterbutter mein
lieber scholli das ist echt lecker das
eine richtig gute kräuterbutter gibt auf
jeden fall zehn von zehn haben blätter
kräuterbutter gewürz 399 schmeckt viel
besser was hat mir der weihnachtsmann
berlins nahe gebracht
huhu handel mit hochwertigen
omega-3-fettsäuren im perfekten
verhältnis zu meinem blut also hanföl
soll super gesund sein genauso wie beim
hanf mail hat das viele omega 3 und
omega 6 fettsäuren
das ist gut für haut und haar und für
die ganze gesundheit wenn ihr euch mal
zur hand gelesen wollt ich war sehr
überrascht muss ich sagen ich wusste
nicht dass hans so gut ist für den
körper
wollen wir mal testen wieder schmecken
ich hab irgendwann mal beim italiener
brot in olivenöl reingepackt und seitdem
stehe ich so auch öl ich fand früher öl
eigentlich immer eklig und mittlerweile
täglich warum es halt so viele
verschiedene geschmäcker von öl liegt
auf jeden fall ähnlich wie olivenöl
die pure essenz das ist echt lecker das
schmeckt mir sogar besser als olivenöl
wenn ihr nicht viel mit öl anfangen
könnt ist es in ordnung aber falls euch
das interessiert hanföl sehr gut preis 6
euro 20 400 milliliter ich lieb ist ja
dass überall diese hand blättert raubs
und das macht irgendwie so böse hans
schenner aufstrich zucchini 35 prozent
zusammen sind da drin
hergestellt in oberschwaben gibt ein
bisschen wie baby bereit
okay ich bin aber schon ein bisschen
enttäuscht weil ich dachte dass hans
produkte nach hand schmecken also nach
gras aber tun sie nicht christlich
köstlich bisschen salzig ein bisschen
sehr sich aber sehr sehr lecker
hingeschaut baby bereits jetzt kommt
etwas worauf ich sehr gespannt bin ein
hanf t shirt heimservice einer disc
enthält
es riecht nicht so eklig giftig wie die
anderen sachen textilien aus hanffasern
bieten folgende vorteile naturrein und
ökologisch sinnvoll da ohne pestizide
angebaut feuchtigkeitsregulierend
atmungsaktiv wärmend im winter und
kühlen im sommer 55 prozent und 45
prozent baumwolle
na dann wollen wir doch mal schauen wie
es aussieht wo ich habe einen hand t
shirt ich muss sagen ich finde es extrem
cool und es fühlt sich unglaublich gut
der stadt ist so robuster und härter als
normale t shirts und ich glaube ich weiß
was gemeint ist mit diesem wärme im
winter und kühlen im sommer das ist
wirklich ein guter stoff ist einfach
angenehmer es gibt so t shirt oder so
oberteile die du anziehst und schon
merkt das ist so ein oberteil da werde
ich voll drin schwitzen und es wird
richtig stehen ihm ist ganz genau was
ich meine
ich finde es richtig geil 9 euro 90 denn
es war ein angebot daran erinnere ich
mich glaube es hat vorher 20 um gekostet
ich hab's für 10
gekauft hat aber auch eine gute form
nächstes produkt cookies da musste ich
wirklich lachen als ich das im internet
gesehen habe coupies kunden wir mal habe
ich von diesen keksen auch hier werden
fünf euro 19 okay die sind
wahrscheinlich wieder handgemacht
haferflocken margarine zu können und
geschick haben zu sagen weil diese zu
kaputten okay
sie sehen aber gut aus aber es sieht
alles aus als ob kräuter dran wären ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob ich mir regelmäßig
für fünf euro 19 kekse holen würde
aber ich finde das ist so ein richtig
geiles geschenk einfach weil man bei
hans cookies an etwas anderes denkt als
kekse mit hanf drittel was dich nicht
hey macht sondern halt was ist ein guter
butterkeks ein bisschen knuspriger
klinge in haferflocken jetzt seid ihr
richtig gespannt was kommt als nächstes
ist gebrannte handzahm
die sehen aus wie so kleine körner halt
einfach crazy das schmeckt wie der
dunkle teil bei popcorn also da wo der
mais ist oder war oder das was von ihm
übrig ist aber es ist bei ich es hat den
geschmack von diesem harten maiskorn ist
aber weiß man kann ganz normal gut kauen
und mein gott das ist ein lecker okay
dass ich gut 499 für seine packung
gebrannte hand müsse aber geil ich werde
das einfach hier überall in meiner
wohnung verteilen wächst das so gut wenn
es so klein ist dann muss man sich so
mühe geben das so in seinen mund zu
stecken anstatt wieso bei popcorn muss
der andere sucht einschieben kann
es hört auch nicht aufnehmen hans
schokolade mit nußbach
und vollmilchschokolade mit hanf komplex
und kaffeegeschmack sorry mehr 73 eur 9
prozent diese tafel und 229 die hier
teuer wäre es günstig beide sind nicht
kannst es sieht aus wie normale strobl
weiter auch normale schokolade ist sehen
wir auch super kräuter drin wäre ich
schmecke aber nichts anderes aber sehr
lecker kommen wir zur crazy dunklen
schwarzen kaffee gras schokolade
ich weiß nicht warum man eine hand
schokolade kaufen sollte nur weil man
das gesunde von hanf haben möchte weil
anscheinend ist ja hanf ziemlich gesund
hmm ich liebe einfach diese tests videos
für schokolade und kekse essen kann
besser geht es doch nicht was kommt als
nächstes hans pesto basilico fünf euro
49 für hans pesto basilico es nach der
schokolade so ein bisschen eklig okay
leute hans pesto basilico ich muss sagen
ich bin noch nicht hey ich fühle mich
absolut noch wie am anfang das auch
schon wieder so salzig ist auf jeden
fall auch lecker schmeckte jetzt kein
hand oder so aber pump ist anscheinend
auch einfach nicht so geschmackvoll als
ich nämlich gesehen habe dass es so
viele hanfprodukte gibt dachte ich dass
hanf einen eigengeschmack hat es sich
lohnt produkte damit zu machen also sind
schokolade rente packen oder nüsse
obwohl jetzt echt gut waren oder in
keksen und die produkte schmecken lecker
aber es ist halt nichts besonderes ist
jetzt nicht so um ihr ist hans schreckt
aber ganz super da drin wir sind schon
bei unseren letzten produkt angekommen
und zwar hans täters sind einfach nur
hans blätter aus denen man einen tee
machen kann und da ich in letzter zeit
sehr gerne mag dachte ich es könnte ja
riesig welling werden das sieht aus
es riecht wie heu ja für jemanden joint
rauchen
lasst uns daraus einen tee machen
heißes wasser und hand stehplätze
together cherry sieht auf jeden fall
sehr hip aus mit dem beutel und so habe
ich in so einem hipster kaffee werde und
meine hand tee trinke 499 na gut also
ist gut bei darmerkrankungen und bei
magenproblemen es ist gut gegen stress
und für das immunsystem es sollte eine
stimmung aufhellen also bei depressiven
verstimmungen sage ich mal soll es wohl
wirken es soll kämpfe lösen und
schmerzlinderung klingt doch erst mal
sehr gut war das gefühl was gesundes zu
trinken und das ist auch mal nicht
schlecht
ich muss man den teebeutel rausholen zu
der farbe von dem team muss ich nichts
sagen da wir alle woran ich denke was
haben wir heute gelernt wir haben heute
auf jeden fall gelernt dass hans ganz
schön gesund sein soll
das hanf in produkten nicht wirklich
raus schmeckbar ist also nicht für
normale zungen die meine
aber wenn es so einen positiven
nebeneffekt hat wie gute fettsäuren gut
für die verdauung gut für eigentlich den
ganzen körper also dein ganzer körper
findet hand eigentlich ziemlich klasse
sogar auf der haut also ich muss sagen
sehr angenehmes gefühl also die ganze
das ziel getragen zu haben es juckt
nicht es hat nichts ist es einfach es
fühlt sich gut an auf der haut ich weiß
was ich meine
und wenn man das alles so betrachtet und
das hanf echten gutes ding also nicht
nur zu sondern auch zum einnehmen habt
ihr erfahrungen mit hans produkten habt
ihr schon mal bei erkrankungen oder
sowas hanfprodukte benutzt und habt euch
danach besser gefühlt gibt es von euch
noch irgendwelche hanf tipps schreibt
sie alle in die kommentare ich bin sehr
gespannt wie eure erfahrung mit hanf ist
das ist für mich noch ein gebiet das
habe ich noch nie mitbekommen hatte für
mich bis jetzt noch keinen wert in
meinem leben ich bin gespannt ob ich
irgendwelche verbesserungen merke wenn
ich viel hanföl und
produkte zu mir nehme und ja dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder
ich hoffe euch geht's gut es ist dunkel
geworden im sommer ist es dann wieder
zum glück länger hell
ich sollte noch ein paar stücke von
diesem tee trinken
der soll ja anscheinend meine stimmung
aufhellen bis dann leute
[Musik]